at least two people have been killed and
several others injured in myanmar after
police fired live ammunition to disperse
protesters
in the city of mandalay
the crowds were forced to flee as
security forces chased after them using
slingshots
rubber bullets and water cannon the
protesters were repeating their call for
an
end to a military coup that took place
more than two weeks ago
similar demonstrations took place in the
economic center yangon where people paid
tribute to a woman who police shot dead
last week during another protest
for more i'm joined by an activist in
mandalay we're calling him
sam to protect his identity but it isn't
his real name
sam you've been speaking to people who
were out on the streets today
give us a sense of what the situation
was like out there
yeah so today though the police actually
you know
came into the uh shipping docks in
mentally and they wanted to
pressure the workers who are
participating in civil disobedience
movement
so the um people surrounding
in the neighborhoods came out and they
protest to you know stop the police
and the police started shooting people
and one was shot through the head and
the other was shot
through the ribs and many other was uh
severely injured
so this is uh getting very virulent yes
indeed how worried are you and the other
protesters about this
escalating military crackdown
yes so we all know this uh sooner or
later they were
there there was going to be black shed
that uh
we're not or we're not uh scared because
uh this is uh we have to you know uh
put an end to this uh military hunter
so this is uh uh we're gonna fight till
the end
and um i don't know how many
people are going to be killed uh in the
coming days but
we're not gonna back down where do you
see this going i mean from your
perspective
is there still hope that a peaceful
solution can be found
yeah so um as far as i
am concerned uh there won't be any uh
compromise between
us and the military hyundai because uh
in the past we all seen
the things and the violence they have
brought upon the people and
we all know we all know this and we are
going to
have to you know put an end to this so
uh
this is either the default or we do
sam thank you thank you for giving us
that perspective sam an activist in the
city of mandalay whose name we have
changed to protect his identity
you